hi everybody how are you all doing okay
cool
so I just want to start let me just open
this up here for a second can you hear
me okay by the way okay cool so I
already got a sweet intro there thank
you very much but just really quickly
about me that's an actual photo of me
those aren't yes those are my real
biceps my real tattoos 100% I'm a web
application developer I work at a
software consulting agency and twg and I
see a couple TW tears here hi I also
teach at hacker u which is a
toronto-based coding bootcamp as well as
at Canada learning code and Emma mentor
MTA with the bridge school and I'm gonna
be like tweeting I already actually
messed up my timing on this I already
live tweeted the slides for this talk so
if you want to cheat and get ahead or
later if you want to see the slides just
follow me on Twitter I posted them there
so I wanted to start by this this talk
is called the react cookbook and I
wanted to start just with a show of
hands how many people here cook without
following a recipe how many people here
cook without following recipe so I'm
very very impressed because personally I
have to say that like that is not an
ability I have but I'm sure that y'all
when you go to the grocery store you
don't even bring an ingredient list with
you you like squeeze produce and like
smell it
just to like no that's freshness or
pluck it's leaves or whatever and you go
home you cut up all your ingredients you
know what you want to make you you go
home and you end up with something that
looks like this and I'm very envious of
you I think that's very very impressive
I on the other hand don't have this
ability I need to follow a recipe in
fact here's Halloween's coming up I was
doing a little bit of October cooking
here's a live look of me doing a bit of
cooking so definitely not a strength
that I have personally and this is the
output of what I produce I think you
should give me marks for presentation
personally you know I it's a bit of a
Halfmoon arrangement there but yeah like
I typically need to follow a recipe and
I find that when I follow a recipe I do
end up with delicious tasting
food and what I wanted to share with you
is that I also find that when I follow
code recipes I end up with delicious
tasting react apps now you might be like
a co and see what I did there and you
might be thinking like a code recipe
well what is a code recipe well we
actually have a name for this in
development this is what's called a
design pattern a design pattern and what
is a design pattern the definition of a
design pattern according to I believe
Wikipedia is a academic source is a
solution to a recurring problem a zine
pattern is a solution to a recurring
problem so for example we have some kind
of recurring software problem we follow
a design pattern and we end up with some
kind of delicious desirable code based
outcome so what I want you to do is I
want you to think about design patterns
as the kind of recipes that help us cook
delicious react apps and the goal of
this talk it's called the react cookbook
the goal of this talk is to add some
recipes to your cookbook so we're gonna
be adding a few different recipes to
your cookbook so that the next time that
you work on a react app or even the
current react app that you're working on
you can kind of cook with these recipes
and end up with a presentation that
looks better than that brie half-circle
so we're gonna be learning these recipes
and I just want to say that these are
not recipes that I created I didn't
invent them they're recipes that I have
kind of gathered and collected from my
time building react apps and
specifically these are recipes that I
would attribute to what I call the react
top chefs so here we have chef Dan
Abramov and we're gonna be looking at a
few different chefs and will point out
the chef as we get to them and talk
about the specific pattern that either
they created or they championed
something like that so for our cookbook
today the recipes that we're going to be
learning about we're gonna learn about
three recipes we're going to learn about
the context API we're gonna learn about
a pattern called presentation and
container components and then we're
gonna learn about render props if any of
you attended the West boss workshop I
believe he actually covered some of
these as well
so I'm glad we're not like on the same
day in the same slot so we're gonna
start by doing some cooking and we're
going to start with
first recipe now our first recipe that
we're going to talk about is the context
API this is a recipe that was championed
by I first heard about it by Kent C
Dodds it's also been a part of react for
a very very very long time
however a new version of it came out
quite recently and when it did
Kent Dawes who has a newsletter where he
talks about just different react
patterns things that he's excited about
libraries that he's working on he kind
of reintroduced the idea of using the
context API so I think this is a
statement that you can all kind of agree
with I think when people first encounter
react and the idea of passing props
inside of a react app it can be very
very frustrating now if you're passing
props like let's say one level down here
we have an app component that's passing
some props to a menu component that's
not that big of a deal but what happens
if you have for example a sign out
component and you want your dashboard to
pass a prop into it well if it is
rendered by an intermediary component in
this case the sidebar component we have
to pass it through side bar in order to
get it into sign out and we have to do
this even if the side bar component
doesn't even use that prop at all so we
end up passing this prop down our tree
through a component that doesn't even
need it and that's like not the best but
then you can end up in a situation like
this where you have to pass it through a
side bar through settings into a reset
password component so we're passing this
prop down multiple layers inside of our
app this is problematic because we end
up passing this prop through a bunch of
intermediary components that don't eat
it it's also possible that through this
journey during this time as it moves
between all of these props sometimes it
changes names for some reason the
developer decides it's gonna be called
something else
and so later when you come back and you
try and find the origin of this prop you
have like four or five files open as
you're trying to track it all the way
back up the chain there's actually a
name for this and again Kent Dodds was
the first person I heard use this before
but he refers to this as prop drilling
or prop threading is another name that
I've heard for this mmm and prop
drilling is really really frustrating
and I think especially when people are
new to react it's something that they
experienced quite early on in their
journey if you were to ask like someone
at your work I'm having this issue with
prop drilling I keep passing this prop
down the chain and I want to know is
there an easier way to kind of resolve
this issue they might say something to
you like oh you should use redox so then
you go okay I've heard of redox maybe
you've used it before I'm just gonna go
check the documentation and see what it
says so you end up looking at like a
diagram that looks like that and you're
sort of like why is this so hard like
all I wanted to do is just like pass a
prop down without having to pass it
through the intermediary components so
why do I now have to add the boilerplate
how would I have to manage the overhead
of redox and the truth is is it's hard
because like sometimes we want our state
to be global but react the kind of
unidirectional data flow of react the
whole model that data moves from the top
down react doesn't really want us to
have or access global State in this way
there's no real way immediately visible
to you to access parent state from a
deeply nested component until now
actually it's always been there but it's
become more popular recently but yes
until now so this is an introduction to
the first recipe we're going to be
talking about today this recipe is
called the context API this definition
comes from the react Docs which are
great and it just says a way to pay past
data through the component tree without
having to pass props down manually at
every single level so literally what we
just described this gives us the ability
to access a prop from lower down our
tree without needing to pass it through
the intermediary components so if we
look at this diagram here this was a
situation we had before we had a profile
component that had to pass a prop from
sidebar and settings so that it could be
accessed by reset pass right here well
with the context API we'll be able to do
this instead so we'll have our parent
component here profile it's going to
have the data that we want to have
accessed by the reset password so how
does the context API actually accomplish
that this it accomplishes it using two
two kind of key components the first one
is called the provider
and you can think of the provider as a
kind of global state container just
picture it kind of like a big object in
the sky essentially so it's some kind of
object that we're gonna have access to
you further down in our chain and the
provider is going to be it's going to
make this information available to us
through another component which is
called the consumer so the consumer has
access to the provider we'll see that
anywhere we render the consumer the
consumer in our component tree will have
access to any data that is stored inside
of the provider without needing to pass
that data down the tree so setting it up
is actually really really
straightforward and if any of you have
experience with redux I think you'll
appreciate the simplicity of this in
comparison so the first thing that you
do is you call a method that's actually
just built in to react you call react
create context and here we're
destructuring to components off of the
create the return value of create
context we're restructuring a provider
component and a consumer component and
then what we're going to do is at the
top of our state tree we're going to
wrap our entire app inside of this
provider component or at least we're
going to wrap the part of our app that
we want to have access to this
information elsewhere in the provider
component we're gonna pass a prop of
value this is a prop that is like
predefined and whatever we pass into
value that's going to be accessible by
the consumer and the consumer is going
to be rendered somewhere else in our
tree below so it just needs to be
rendered in a component that is a child
of the provider so for example let's
imagine we have an app component that's
storing a little bit of user data in its
state here we have like a user name of
guy fieri
excellent cook and what we're gonna do
is we're gonna take this user data you
can imagine this came from an API or
something like that we're not going to
worry about that part of it it's not
relevant for this but we're gonna take
that data and we're gonna pass it into
the provider component through this
value prop here so you can see that
we're passing the entire state tree here
we're passing this state into the
provider and within the provider you can
see that we render a dashboard component
now the dashboard component doesn't
receive any props we're not passing this
data user into it or anything like that
and then as we move further down our
tree we can see that our dashboard may
be the dashboard renders the side by
and the site again the sidebar doesn't
take any props in it at all and then in
the sidebar component when we render it
you see that here we're actually also
rendering our consumer component and
inside of our consumer component you see
that we have this function here that
which receives a parameter of value and
if we actually grab value user name will
be able to print out guy fieri so we'll
be able to access this state value from
the top of our tree without needing to
pass it down through intermediary
components as props so just to visualize
what this looks like we have our app
component that has a provider inside of
it and then further down our tree we
have this consumer component which is
accessing data from the provider without
it needing to move in between dash bar
and sideboard you can also have
consumers at multiple levels of your
component tree so if that information
needs to be accessed in multiple
different areas of your app which
oftentimes with user data for example it
does maybe you need to know in a sign
in/sign out whether the user is
currently logged in whereas like
somewhere else you need to know some
other piece of information about their
user authentication you can just render
additional consumers there and each one
of them will have access to that value
from the app component so if you were to
visualize that it would look a little
bit like this we have two different
consumers and both of them are accessing
this data from the provider at different
different branches of your state tree
and you can even get like more complex
than this if you want to so you can end
up with something like this where you
have kind of branching branching
components in your app each one of them
that's rendering a consumer that's
subscribing to this provider up here so
the huge benefits of this pattern over
like passing the props down or anything
else is essentially we're eliminating
this issue of prop drilling of needing
to pass this prop down multiple levels
inside of our app and we're also
eliminating the need for Redux at this
juncture in our application this is I
want to just a caveat with this like
pattern this is not that you don't need
redux you can only you can just use
context API that's not what I'm saying
what I'm saying is a lot of the common
use cases that people initially use
redux for which is to avoid this sort of
prop drilling you can just start by
using the context API so it gives you
the benefit of deferring that decision
to a later date down the road of your
web applications like life and you'll
see that that's also very important like
as we go on being able to defer
decisions until later so when do you use
it when do you use the context API well
you use it when you find yourself
passing props like all the way down your
tree so they can be accessed lower down
if you find that you do have some global
state that you need to know about
everywhere in your app and you will find
that when you build your web application
there are certain things that you need
all in all kinds of different places in
your app like user settings for example
and if somebody tells you that you need
redux just like stop think for a minute
and ask yourself if you can if what
you're trying to do can be accomplished
by the context API and if it can I would
suggest starting there before trying to
learn the overhead and boilerplate
associated with redux so what can you
cook with it with this recipe you can
cook a bunch of stuff some examples
would be like a shopping cart system so
if you do some kind of global shopping
cart management in your app context API
is really good for keeping track of like
whether or not the card is open or
closed or what's in its inventory if
you're doing internationalization so
you're managing translations across your
app and you need to know like what
language is currently active and where
you want to store your translation
strings you can use it for that it's
really helpful for modal's again because
like in different parts of your
application you need to know like how to
be able to open a modal from anywhere or
close it and then it's also really good
for building like a general theme
provider so if you want to have like
specific styling that you want to manage
and like many different levels inside of
your application it's quite useful for
that as well ok so that's the first
recipe that we covered the context API I
now want to introduce you to the second
one and the second one is presentation
or container components this is a comes
from an article that I read in like I
think it was like 2015 so it's like
quite old but I still I actually
maintain that this is probably one of
the most important patterns in react one
of the most important recipes in react
and I actually think it's one of the
most important ideas in web application
architecture period so I really really
recommend that like you not only think
about this in the context of react but
also just in terms of building web apps
so I want you to imagine for a second
that you were asked to build this
weather widget component so we can see
that this weather widget services some
kind of information about the weather
and then it also has this kind of visual
component to it so we're rendering some
kind of content onto the screen so if we
were going to build this we need to kind
of think about two different things
we're gonna need to request some weather
data from our our API that keeps
information about our weather and then
we're gonna display that data on the
page so you're like okay cool I know how
to do this it's like pretty
straightforward I'm gonna build this
component it's gonna be called weather
widget and when the component mounts I'm
gonna request the weather through get
weather and then in the render method
I'm going to just display that content
I'm gonna display the information about
the weather onto the screen this is fine
you're like super stoked about your your
component here it's like really small
very portable etc but then what happens
is over time you actually need to do
more stuff here they want you to add
like a 12 day forecast to it be able to
show like Fahrenheit and Celsius all
kinds of other things about the weather
I don't really understand how the
weather works but they want you to do
all this other stuff and so you start to
expand your component and it ends up
looking a little bit like that and that
is bonkers this is so big that I had to
like zoom out and take two screenshots
in order to get it to fit on the screen
and this this component is suffering
from what I would describe is like this
is a bloated component this is a
component that is too big and why is
this problematic this is problematic for
kind of three main reasons it's really
difficult to reason about when I say
reason about I mean it's really hard to
look at it and understand like wTF is
going on do you know what I'm saying
like it's really hard to know what it's
doing because there's so much code there
it's really hard to modify and reuse so
like you try and change it and it like
breaks or you just can't really use it
in multiple places because it's so
specific to the one area where it's
being used and it's also super
unfriendly to other developers like it
feels like you can't tuck no one can
touch that component because if anybody
touches that component it's just gonna
explode into a million pieces so how do
we avoid this how do we avoid this
pattern of like these bloated components
that are like untouchable and really
scary so this is the pattern this so it
was proposed
by Dan Abramov in this 2015 article
presentational and container components
and the key idea of this article is an
idea that's not exclusive to react but
he's introducing the notion of
separation of concerns separation of
concerns is an incredibly powerful
concept when it comes to web application
architecture and just programming in
general what do we mean by a concern a
concern is literally just something your
code is responsible for some thing your
your code cares about and if we think
about our weather widget component it
kind of cares about two things it cares
about fetching data and it also cares
about displaying data so these are our
two concerns and then the idea of
fetching data this is a logic based
concern it has to do with like managing
state going and requesting data from the
API and then displaying that data on the
screen that's a UI concern it has to do
with like a visual representation of
something so what Dan Abramov proposes
in this recipe is he proposes that we
take these two kind of disparate but
connected things and we actually
separate them into two different
components first we have our container
component and our container component is
going to be responsible for managing the
logic of our weather widget and then we
have our presentation component our
presentation component is going to be
responsible for the user interface it's
gonna be responsible for what the user
actually sees let's start by talking
about the container component the
container component is responsible for
what our widget actually does in our
case or other aka the logic so in our
case the widget is responsible for
getting data and storing that data in
state and what Dan Abramov proposes is
he proposes that we call this component
whatever the thing is container so we
have weather widget container in this
case and if we look at like what this
component actually looks like we have
this component did mount here which
requests the it requests the data and
stores it in state and that's all the
container is going to be responsible for
it's just going to be responsible for
requesting the data and storing it in
state but what about the render like
what is the actual UI for this look like
well that's where we introduced the
presentational component the
presentational component is what the
thing looks like and again Dan Abramov
if the container is called like weather
widget container we just lock the word
container off here and we call the
presentational component weather widget
so now we have these two components this
weather widget container per component
and this weather widget component and
what will happen is that the container
will actually render this weather widget
component it will render it and it will
pass in any data that the weather widget
needs to know about in our case it's
going to pass in the state data that's
keeping track of information about the
weather and then the weather widget
component our presentational component
it looks like this so what it's doing is
all it's responsible for all it's
concerned with is receiving some props
which have information about the weather
in them and then rendering those onto
the screen so there's a couple of things
you'll notice really quickly right off
the bat the first is that we can use a
functional component here we don't need
to use a class-based component and the
reason that we can do that is because
we're not there's no state being managed
in this component and there's no
lifecycle methods being managed in this
component and what that means is that
this is a much much much simpler
component and therefore like a much
easier to reason about component the
only thing that this component is
concerned with is displaying some
content onto the screen based on some
data that it received so why is this
pattern useful this container component
and presentational component pattern
it's useful because it's it makes the
code a lot more reasonable easy to read
I mean sorry so if you go back and you
think about if you think about that
bloated component that we were looking
at before we've taken that content and
we split it into two different
components and and that is going to make
it a lot easier for us to also hunt down
bugs basically what we can do is if we
see that there's some kind of
information some kind of issue with the
data that's coming back from the API or
something's not being set in state
properly something that is kind of a
logic based issue we know that we need
to debug this inside of the container
similarly if we look at the thing on the
screen and as we look at it it looks as
the kids say jacked it looks messed up
then we know that that's a that's a
presentational issue that's a visual
issue and we can debug that inside the
presentational
so we're able to really isolate our
potential technical issues with our
components and debug them in a way that
is like we'll just be able to debug
faster and we'll have more confidence in
our approach technically this pattern
also makes the the presentational
component the weather widget reusable in
other places if we wanted it to I'm a
little bit skeptical about this this is
something a Dan Abramov says I'm a bit
skeptical about it because it requires
that presentational component to receive
the identical props as it would from the
current container but theoretically if
you had another container elsewhere and
passed data into this component you
could theoretically use that
presentational weather widget elsewhere
and then the other thing that's really
good about this pattern is that it's
much more testable so for your
presentational component if you're
familiar with snapshot testing you would
you could easily write a snapshot test
for this and just mock the props that
are being passed in then you have like
total coverage on that component you're
good to go and then for the container
component that one you could unit test
with more of a kind of logic based
approach so the question is like when do
when do I use it when do I know to use
this particular recipe this
presentational and container component
recipe well you some of the like early
signs essentially if you look at your
component and you're like damn this is
doing too many things that's probably a
good sign that you can split it out in
some way and this approach of separation
of concerns is a good way to start if
you look at it and you're like oh this
component is responsible both for
determining what something looks like as
well as like what it does or like some
kind of logic based work you probably
want to split these into two components
also literally you could just count the
number of lines if it has like thousands
and thousands of lines inside of it it's
the component is too big and it needs to
be split out into these kind of separate
concerns these separate components so
this pattern the pattern of
presentational and container components
is incredibly powerful it's something
that you can use in small apps and in
massive apps so it's a very very
scalable pattern and they will
immediately make your codebase more
manageable so I really really recommend
that like when you're working on your
react apps whether it's like your next
one in your current one or if you're
building a view app or whatever just ask
yourself like do I have good separation
of concerns in my application have I
separated my presentation layer from my
logic layer and I think start
introducing this pattern into your app
and you'll find immediately your app is
like more pleasurable for you to work
with and also for other developers to
work with as well okay that's our second
recipe so that was the presentational
container components we talked about
context API and now I'm gonna talk about
our third one
our third pattern that we're gonna talk
about our third recipe is called render
props and render props have been
popularized by a lot of different
developers it's actually now part of the
react documentation so like you'll see
them in there as well but I kind of
first heard about it through a talk by
chef Michael Jackson and he's an
incredible incredibly smart developer
who has a lot of really awesome ideas
and he gave this talk about the value of
render props and to explain like why you
would use render props in the app I'm
gonna kind of imagine a hypothetical
scenario where we're building a puppy
voting app so we're gonna build an app
here that's essentially for voting on
adorable puppies so like people see a
photo of a puppy and they can either say
that it's like adorable or like
incredibly adorable that's like
basically the scale so you're like okay
cool I'm gonna start building this app
and I first thing I need to do is I need
to build this puppy feed component cuz I
need to go get some puppies it's not for
feeding puppies it's like a feed of
puppies I need to go get them
from the API so you're like cool I'm
gonna build this puppy feed component
this this whole example by the way was
just like an excuse to like Google a
bunch of images of cute animals so the
first thing that you're gonna do is
you're like okay I need to make an API
request to slash API slash puppies while
we're waiting for this puppy data to
come back because there's a lot of
adorable puppies we'll service a loading
spinner and then when the puppies come
home we're gonna render them onto the
screen and if there's an error like
we're unsuccessful in retrieving the
puppies which would be so sad then we
will render the error on the screen so
you build this and you're like dope this
looks incredible super excited it's
testing while in the focus groups and
your manager she comes to you and she
says this is great can you also can we
do the same thing but
we do it with kittens like let's do it
like a kitten feet as well and so you're
like okay cool yeah no problem we'll
follow a similar pattern here what we're
gonna do get slash API slash kittens
we're gonna surface a loading spinner
and we're gonna render some adorable
kittens if there is an error we will
render the error and you kind of look at
this and you go interesting interesting
very interesting
in fact like we're kind of doing the
same thing twice right we're requesting
this thing servicing a loading spinner
rendering adorable creatures and then if
there's an error rendering an error and
you go the only real difference between
these two is like one renders puppies
and the other one renders kittens so
you're like okay you put your dry hat on
or do not repeat yourself hat you go
there's this is an abstraction
opportunity you get very excited and you
say let's create a pet feed and the way
that this pet feed is gonna work is that
you're gonna pass it a pet as a prop so
you say like pet feed pet is equal to
kittens and that will get you kittens
and pet feed pet is equal to puppies and
that will get you puppies and you're
like don't crush tit now that I've got
this amazing abstraction here it works
for kittens and puppies later if we
wanted to have adorable Turtles we could
probably use it for that too there's
like a high high level of potential with
this the next feature that that your
lead she comes to you and she says okay
this is awesome we're doing really well
and now what we want to do is we want to
have like a user profile and the user
profile is oh the user profile is it's
going to do a couple of things that's
going to get information about the user
and surface that data into the screen so
you go okay cool it we're gonna do get
slash API slash profile we're gonna
surface a loading spinner you get the
idea it's very very similar pattern and
then you go oh it's just interesting
this is kind of like the pet feed it
actually does the exact same things as
the pet feed except it renders a user's
profile and then you think like but the
presentation of this is going to be
different we're not gonna have a gallery
of adorable pets maybe we're gonna have
some like inputs here where you can like
type in like change the password or
something like that so you're like how
do I like kind of like blend these
things how do I use my pet feed
component here do I need to abstract
that or
I need to use like duplicate logic here
in order to like make this work for the
settings page and while you're kind of
like thinking about the best way to do
this
your manager comes to you and is like oh
I had this awesome idea we want to do
this depending on if it's loading
puppies or if it's loading kittens we
want to actually have like a different
spinner so like if it's puppies you
wanna have this like little dog prancing
around and if it's kittens we want this
like weird mystic upside down floating
kitten and so you think like oh well
actually they're like the same component
and like I don't know maybe I need to
add like a conditional statement in the
component if it pet is equal to puppy
then show that or a kitten and you sort
of start realizing that your pet feed
component is like on the cusp of
becoming like spaghetti essentially at
this point it's it's it's an abstraction
that's not working for you and we can't
use it for the user settings page either
so what happened like we had such good
intentions with our abstraction so why
did this happen well the reason this
happened is because tight coupling of
our logic and presentation made our
component less reusable and flexible so
because we connected our logic and our
presentation to each other we kind of
got backed into a corner prematurely so
the solution to this is a pattern called
render props and render props there's a
lot of like confusing language around
render props this is actually the
definition of render prop a render prop
is a simple technique for sharing code
between react components like really at
a core fundamental level that's what a
render prop is used for it's just used
for you have some logic you have a bunch
of components that want to use that
logic so let's use this render prop
pattern this render prop recipe in order
to share it and it looks like this the
reason it's called a render prop by the
way is because the name of the prop
typically it doesn't have to be called
this but the name of the proper a
typically that you use in order to like
take advantage of the render prop a turn
is called render which is kind of
confusing because like that's also
something that a component does it like
renders something but I just want to
point out that like if this prop was
called pizza then this would be called
the pizza prop pattern so this can kind
of have whatever name that you want so
we need to think about how we can
actually use this render prop in our app
for our three different scenario
we have this user settings page this kid
in kittens feed and this puppies feed
and the way that we can kind of use this
is we need to realize that like there
are things that these components have in
common they all request data from the
API
they all need loading States and they
all have error states but actually the
way that they render is quite different
like they all render different things
the pet and kitten feed render things
related to adorable kittens the user
component renders like settings and they
also render different loading spinners
now and potentially later could render
different error states as well so we
have all these different presentational
concerns that we're not going to know
about yet and again as I said before we
want to try and defer the
decision-making around like what they
look like
till the latest time possible so they
have common logic and different
presentation and the way that we're
going to resolve this issue is by
renaming our pet food component we're
gonna call it a resource component
instead and this is a pattern that I
used recently in an app at work it was
very very very successful approach I'd
say this component ended up being used
like I don't know maybe 50 times in
different places in the app and like
generally like my new thinking about
react and like building apps is like if
you write a component that a bunch of
other developers are using in a bunch of
different places and it's working for
all of their use cases and it doesn't
have like a million props that's
something to be really excited about
that's something that you kind of want
to shoot for this awesome reusability so
how do we use this render prop a turn
it's actually very very straightforward
this is the key though when you're doing
a render prop approach what you need to
do is in this resource component this
research component that we're creating
you'll see that in the render method we
call this dot props dot render this stop
props dot render and again remember we
said that render could be called pizza
in which case this would be this dot
props pizza so don't get confused by the
word render here it's not doing anything
magical it's literally just a prop that
is a function that you're calling and
what you pass into this function you
pass in the information from the state
that you want to care about later in our
case we want to care about our payload
our payload is going to contain our
puppies it'll contain our kittens it
will contain our user settings it's just
going to contain an API payload of data
and we also want to know whether
it's currently loading so we want to
know whether that data has arrived or
it's on the way if we were managing an
error state here as well which we
probably should be but just to keep the
example small we would also keep error
information here so if in our request
the request failed we would store that
information in the state here you go the
way that we use this is like very
straightforward so we have the r2 props
here we have a path prop and you'll see
that we're actually using that in our
component did mount here we call you
know Axios get and we pass this dart
props up path that tells us what
endpoint we want to hit and so what we
say is a resource component want to
access this path and we're gonna pass in
our render prop here and our render prop
is going to have this data payload and
this data payload is literally just the
state of the resource component so
inside of there we're gonna have access
to data dot loading and data dot payload
and if we had an error and like we're
handling errors here we'd have access to
data dot error as well if we wanted to
so we have access to all these props
here and what that means is that we can
actually defer the decision-making
around how these components render to
the specific place that we want them to
render so here for example this is the
component that we're using on our puppy
feed page so we can actually handle all
the presentation around showing a puppy
in this view without needing to worry
about making the request knowing if like
the duplicating the logic around like
whether it's loading or not any of those
sorts of things so all we're concerned
with is the actual presentation here and
similarly we can do the exact same thing
with kittens right so we can see that
all we need to change here is our path
we just changed our path and then we
have access to the same properties we
have access to the payload etc but this
time it will have our kittens inside of
it and even the user profile page which
is like completely different than the
other ones all that logic around
requesting loading etc that can all be
handled by our resource component and in
here we can have like a completely
different style of presentation we could
have inputs etc and we're able to handle
all of those things in this view without
needing to worry about duplicating the
logic around how they're actually how
that information is required
did also incidentally like the first
pattern that we looked at the context
API if you remember the way that the
consumer worked is it had this value
inside of it
that uses a render prop as well so this
is a pattern that's really permeating
its way through the react ecosystem
you've ever used react router react
router has a render prop as well all of
these kind of recipes are all kind of
intermingled with each other so the idea
here is we have the same logic but we
have different presentation we were able
to defer our presentation to a later
time which means when we get our you
know fourth request for some other kind
of API type thing we need to do that's
not the same as user profiles or the
same as pets or kittens we'll still be
able to use this resource component so
this component is incredibly flexible
and it's like looking towards the future
for future uses that is a massive win
especially when you start scaling a web
application because when you like at twg
we work in a very iterative way we're
discovering requirements like you know
on Monday and implementing them on
Tuesday so the more components you have
that will help you build things you
didn't know you had to build yet the
more valuable this will be in the long
run so prop ready props I think are one
of the most important patterns Michael
Jackson also in another in that same
talk argues that actually they
completely replace the need for higher
order components which is like a
discussion for another time but it's an
interesting idea they document
incredibly well they kind of use the
declarative style that we're used to
with react so they kind of follow the
the react spirit of doing things it
makes it really easy when you look at a
component at a glance to understand how
it works they separate presentation from
logic again because they allow you to
defer that presentation to a later time
and they also decrease code duplication
because you only have to write our
resource component once and we can use
it anywhere they're super extendable so
other people can build on top of them
really easily they're incredibly
reusable again like proof is in the
pudding this resource component I built
I got used way more times than any
component I've ever written and they
also abstract away logic which is
important for a language that doesn't
have the notion of privacy because
privacy doesn't really exist in react
I'm sorry in JavaScript there needs to
be ways that you can signal to another
developer that's looking at your code
like hey here's the things that here's
the public facing API here's the things
you should be concerned about and then
kind of abstract away the parts it's
like you don't need to worry about this
this is kind of internal stuff that is
managed by the component itself when to
use them don't ever start with a render
prop this is like a just a general
philosophy I would really encourage
don't prematurely abstract anything wait
until you have to use it like three
times before you abstract it and the
reason why I recommend that is because
if you prematurely abstract anything you
will get the abstraction wrong and the
reason that you'll get the abstraction
wrong is because you don't know the use
case for it yet so wait until you need
to use it three times and then hopefully
usually at that point and another
developer on your team will be like oh I
noticed that you wrote the same thing
three times this could probably be
abstracted and you will be like you are
correct share logic between components
but not UI you kind of always want to do
this that's a huge benefit other
developers can what other developers if
you want other developers to reuse your
code which like these days is like the
number one thing that gets me excited
about programming is when I see other
developers using components that I wrote
it makes me so happy when you'd want to
defer rendering UI to a later date when
you were dealing with common States or
events so for example if you need to
manage I was working on a react native
project where we needed to know whether
the keyboard was open or closed and
stuff like that it's really really
useful for those kinds of common events
as well
okay so just some final thoughts all of
these patterns have to do with managing
state and I don't think that's a
coincidence managing state I have heard
it said I think was Kyle Simpson who
said this that 90% of bugs come from
improper state management or just like
not having control of your state
management so just remember that if you
truly understand the state in your app
that means that you will be able to have
a fine-grained control over your app
also some of these patterns are actually
more verbose then like a more abstract
and that's okay because the goal is
never to actually write dry code the
goal is to write code that is easy for
other people to understand that's like
the ultimate goal don't worry about it
being too verbose if it's so terse it's
like one line and nobody can read it
it's useless it will never get used
again cool so this is our cookbook this
is your new cookbook that we kind of
like worked on together here we had our
Kent C Dodds homemade delicious lock-on
text API presentation container
component
ah ah Abramov and chef Jackson's render
props suit I forgot the X on graph
souffl that's supposed to be souffle
also I think there's supposed to be an
accent anyway my French teacher would be
so disappointed in me right now so these
are the three recipes that we learned
about today I just want to say really
quickly that recipes are important for a
couple reasons they're battle-tested
which means that chefs have gone into
the lab with the sommelier z' they've
had done tastings got feedback read Yelp
reviews etc they have a really good
understanding of what is going to use be
useful in them in the most use cases
they're super easy to share because
they're agnostic of code bases they're
just patterns you can use in any code
base they're really fun to use they're
kind of like a choose-your-own-adventure
that only has like a good path which
again like none of you cook with a
recipe so maybe you don't want that but
there I find them really pleasurable
because when I use them I have
confidence that they're actually going
to work really well and they're also
familiar so if I see another chef
cooking or ooh I can say to her hey I
know that recipe here if you need to do
something else I can kind of take over
for a little bit we can trade off so
they give you that kind of familiarity
among a team that's really really useful
and the last thing I want to say is
recipes are just the starting point you
don't need to exclusively follow recipes
they're just a place to start to start
to teach you about some of the important
patterns in your ecosystem once you feel
like you have a good understanding of
these approaches that's when it's time
and they're like in your cookbook that's
when it's time to start writing your own
recipes so that's when you go out and
you start building on these recipes and
you start sharing those with the
community and you start building your
own cookbooks thank you
[Applause]